hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in the beginning of book eight of his
meditations in chapter one Marcus
Aurelius is going to give himself a sort
of assessment and reminder it's
translated here as encouragement to
humility and actually what he's saying
is
so Federer is him telling himself bring
this to Bear bring this to bear on what
can a dog sound so canadoxia is coming
from two different words it's used a lot
in philosophy and also in religious
contexts as well canadoxia is translated
typically as vain Glory kanos means
empty or you know vain something that
doesn't really have value and dogs is
Glory right so you put them together so
somebody who who has kennedoxia is
somebody who's doing actions to look
like a big shot to look like they matter
a common example of this in the Middle
Ages will be giving alms to those who
are begging for them not because you
actually care about them but because you
want to appear to be a certain sort of
person and so what is he particularly
interested in the reputation the
appearance of being a philosopher now he
doesn't mean somebody who is writing
philosophy books teaching philosophy
classes he means somebody who's actually
practicing philosophy so you know a lot
of the ancient philosophies were what we
call philosophies as ways of life and
Marcus is primarily a stoic stoicism was
a philosophy as a way of life you're not
living he's telling himself you're not
showing yourself to really be a
philosopher so he says
you haven't lived uh Bebe okanai your
life your bios as a philosopher now bios
and this this verb that's coming from it
they don't just mean your life as in a
span of time they mean the chosen life
that you are pursuing so we can talk
about for example the life of luxury the
life of commitment the life of right and
so you're not living the life of a
philosopher your life is not reflective
of that whether you're looking at it as
a whole or just from childhood onward as
he's going to say and then he says you
can see how far you are in Greek poro
how distanced you are from philosophy
and not only can you yourself see this
but so can other people all of the other
people right and so he's you know he's
reminding himself because they're will
be some people oh you're a philosopher
king just like Plato was advocating of
the Republican and Marcus is saying I'm
not
I'm not Measuring Up
I haven't been Measuring Up
that's not who I should pretend to be
and then he goes on and tells himself
it's not going to be easy not you know
radios in Greek to acquire literally to
to gain as property to taste thine right
um reputation dokes on of being a
philosopher why not well you know for a
variety of reasons how you've been
behaving you know you're tainted uh and
your position your hypothesis is also a
problem as well so he says well you know
that's not great but now you actually
know how things are and there's a term
that gets left out in some of the
translations
you see truly
you actually understand
how things stand
pukema is the Affairs the way things
actually are in this case my own life
and ketai how they're arranged how
they've come out how they're literally
set down so you see how things are right
I could say the same thing for myself in
other terms you know I'm not going to be
an Olympic 440 yard Runner or something
like that that's long past even though I
did run that race back in high school
yeah look at my body this ain't the body
of a runner right and we could go on and
on from here it's very important to be
realistic with yourself and so what what
should he do given this realization he
tells himself well you know forget what
other people think now it's very
interesting because this term forget
here is office
literally means to let go it comes from
the word to to throw
throw away what other people think of
you this by the way is also the word
that's used or translated as forgive in
the Greek New Testament right so it's
kind of an interesting word to be using
there and then he says you can live the
rest of your life what remains to you as
nature demands of you right as your
human nature demands and he says forget
focus on that don't let anything
distract you you've wandered all over
and finally realized and this is how you
can get to being a fluster you realize
you never found your race right the word
that we get heuristic from you've never
actually encountered
what it is that you're looking for
how to live and not just how to live
actually but how to live well or
literally Living Well
means well Zayn is living and this is
how you know it's been discussed really
since Plato onward you know there's Zayn
living and then there's the good life
what is that and Marcus says you know
you made some mistakes along the way you
didn't find it
in syllogisms
now this is very interesting you didn't
find it in arguments right that's what a
syllogism is
so you didn't find it necessarily by
studying philosophy or doing philosophy
in the academic sense of making
arguments you also didn't find it in
what else in some of the things that he
could have in money Pluto's wealth right
in Fame doksa right again we see this
this doxa coming up you know you don't
have the dokes of a philosopher you also
didn't find what you're looking for in
the dokes of being an important person
nor did you find it in self-indulgence
Indulgence in Pleasures uh is is the the
Greek term there so where are you going
to find how to live the good life right
and here's where he brings up three
questions so this is all part of what
he's reminding himself of right
where is it to be found where is the
good life going to be found in doing POI
in what human nature the nature of a
human being not just nature as a whole
but the distinct nature of a human being
requires epide what it demands what it's
looking for uh interestingly you know
our human nature is looking for us to
behave according to human nature and so
this raises another question
all right how do you do that well
having principles translated here as
first principles
that's actually a little of ambitious of
a translation because the word here is
dogmata this is a very common word in
stoic philosophy gets translated also as
opinions
judgments assumptions a Dogma is
something that you believe or you should
believe right so we've all got plenty of
dogmata the question is whether they're
actually the right ones or not whether
they're in touch with reality or based
on you know mistaken appearances or
imitating bad examples or things like
that so it really does matter what dog
Mata we have because we're going to
operate according to them so having
principles why does this matter so much
because from them come intentions hormai
in Greek this is a technical term for a
stoic philosophy often translated as
impulse or choice
could also be translated I think
successfully as commitments but
intentions also works what it is that we
choose and therefore intend to do what
are we trying to do and then the actual
actions peroxis the things that we do we
get practical from this right so our
principles are very important and so he
says well which principles do I need to
have then is it principles about any old
topic no it's essentially ethical
principles about good and evil or quite
literally about the good things or good
things in general Perry agathon
and bad things Kai kakon right so the
things that matter the things that don't
uh the good things on one side the bad
things on the other side and so what
does this concern here's where we see
you know Marcus giving you could say the
typical stoic line of nothing is good
except for virtue and what leads to
Virtue nothing is bad except the
Opposites of that so nothing is good and
he says good for humans right so he's
not saying nothing is good whatsoever in
the universe he's saying for human
beings what is good for us
nothing is good that does not lead to
and here he lists four things
interestingly three of these are the
cardinal virtues aren't they Justice
Temperance courage
but then he talks about freedom
as translated here as free will but
that's a bit of a mistranslation because
it's
which is the condition of being free as
opposed to being constrained or being a
slave or something like that so it's not
free will as such but rather the state
of being a free being which then would
mean you could exercise Free Will right
so why doesn't he talk about wisdom here
well presumably this is actually part of
wisdom having the right principles or
the right viewpoints about Good and Evil
which is included in the definition of
wisdom when the stoics actually provided
so the freedom you know maybe is
something that we're supposed to Aspire
to and then what's bad well nothing is
bad except what leads to the Opposites
of these what would that be Injustice
lack of self-control when it comes to
pleasures and desires cowardice of you
know varieties uh being you know unable
to see things through would be an
opposite to courage to and then what's
the opposite of freedom on freedom being
a slave the stoics often contract tested
a kind of we could say psychological
freedom and slavery versus the legal
state of being free or enslaved and so
this is supposed to provide him with
sort of a comprehensive overview of how
he's been doing in terms of his life not
great
you know in terms of philosophy and then
what he can do for the rest of his life
and
how he ought to understand what it is
that he's to do for the rest of his life
in order to try to live as a philosopher
from this point onward perhaps with a
little trail of success along the way
and I think this is something that all
of us could take to heart and read
ourselves into in these words written so
long ago that remain very relevant today